à quelle sauce vont-ils être mangé voilà
des semaines que les restaurateurs
attendent les annonces du gouvernement
pour savoir à quoi ressemblera leur été
dans ce quartier animé de toulouse
ceric julia espère pouvoir rouvrir son
établissement dès mardi prochain
nous nous attendions pas évidemment on
va fermer nous pensions que nous
pourrions effectivement avoir des
baisses liées au virus qui se développe
mais de la sq on ferme notre
établissement ça laisse à aller au delà
de tout ce qu'on pouvait imaginer
nous n'avons absolument aucune idée de
la façon dont nous allons pouvoir ré
ouvrir et si on finissait l'exercice
2020 en atteignant 75 80 % du chiffre
d'affaires des années précédentes
je m'estime très satisfait donc nous
sommes 12 je pense qu'à la réouverture
seule une moitié de l'effectif redémarre
à compter du 2 à condition que nous
puissions redémarrer le deux une moitié
de l'effectif le bilan est parfois pire
dans les restaurants voisins c'est le
cas dans celui des rives
un restaurateur qui ne fait que de la
vente à emporter depuis un mois et demi
d'arrêt mois le 2 je continue ma forme
parce que j'ai peur je sais pas qu'est
ce qu'on va pouvoir faire mon récent et
robotique
c'est un bistrot donc c'est l'état de
les unes sur les autres on peut pas de
toute manière
les salariés malheureusement mai
je peux pas les reprendre j'en ai pas
avec moi est avec moi depuis le 15 mai
au 15 avril
et dans l'immédiat je continue comme ça
j'ai pas le choix
je pense peut-être devoir
malheureusement licencier du personnel
mais
parce que je sais pas j'aimerais l'égard
des douces mais
un flou qui devrait se dissiper dans
très peu de temps
le premier ministre doit s'exprimer cet
après midi
[Musique]